[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
[Musik]
guten abend hinein die brutalsten
diktatoren dieser welt die folterknechte
mit ihren geheimen gefängnissen sie alle
haben heute nach koblenz geschaut
vielleicht erstmal nur kurz vielleicht
aber schon mit einem gefühl dass da
etwas auf sie zukommen kann zumindest
wäre das zu wünschen zuallererst ihren
opfern aber auch uns ein das
oberlandesgericht koblenz hat heute
rechtsgeschichte geschrieben hat
eilmeldungen ausgelöst überall in der
welt mit dem urteil im weltweit ersten
strafprozess um starts folter in syrien
lebenslang für den mann der nach
überzeugung des gerichts für grausame
folter von mindestens 4000 menschen in
diesem geheimgefängnis in damaskus
verantwortlich war für 27 morde für
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
alkhatib 3000 kilometer entfernt von
koblenz ein ort hinter der sonne so
nannten in die die ihn überlebt haben
ein ort an dem selbst die blauen fliegen
sich nicht verirren bobby cherry an
berichtet in syrien wurde blogger und
regimekritiker hussein kreher gefoult
hat in koblenz war er nebenkläger und
zeuge hat ausgesagt gegen einen mann der
verantwortlich war für sein leid und
doch ging es in dem verfahren um mehr
als die schuld nur eines einzelnen
täters
ist am wichtigsten ist dass die wahrheit
über die greueltaten in syrien ans licht
gekommen ist
das offizielle dokumente vor einem
ordentlichen gericht einem deutschen
gericht präsentiert worden sind
die zeigen dass diese verbrechen teil
eines größeren bildes sind
27 fachen mord folter verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit dafür wurde der
ehemalige syrische geheimdienst
mitarbeiter an war das lan heute zu
lebenslanger haft verurteilt er selbst
kam als flüchtling nach deutschland
das oberlandesgericht koblenz sah es als
erwiesen an dass der heute 58-jährige
als vernehmung chef in einem syrischen
gefängnis für die folter von mindestens
4000 menschen verantwortlich war ein
wichtiges signal für die opfer so die
anklage
deshalb werden wir als
bundesanwaltschaft im schulterschluss
mit unseren partnern im ausland
weiterhin alles daran setzen dass solche
verbrechen auch in zukunft geahndet
werden
2011 begannen die proteste der syrischen
demokratiebewegung
das assad regime reagierte mit gewalt
verhaftungen und folter
mit dem urteil von heute sei klar
geworden dass kriegsverbrecher nirgendwo
auf der welt sicher sein so
menschenrechts-organisationen das
sogenannte weltrechtsprinzip macht es
möglich dass syrische verbrechen in
deutschland behandelt werden
wir als menschheit haben uns darauf
verständigt das taten die besonders
krass besonders gravierend sind überall
auf der welt verfolgt werden können egal
wo sie passiert sind auch egal an wen
sie verübt wurden und genau auf
grundlage dieses prinzips ist hier heute
dieses urteil erfolgt weltweit
einzigartig
108 verhandlungstage mehr als 80
zeugenaussagen ein zweiter angeklagter
wurde bereits zu viereinhalb jahren haft
wegen beihilfe verurteilt das
internationale interesse am koblenzer
prozess war groß und doch sei das urteil
heute nur ein kleiner schritt sagen
opfer die hose denn viele täter seien
weiter auf freiem fuß und das
systematische folter in syrien gehe
weiter
professor florian jesberger hat den
lehrstuhl für internationales strafrecht
an der berliner humboldt-universität und
nebenkläger in dem prozess begleitet
herr professor guten abend herr sievers
der jetzt verurteilte der ist von
ehemaligen opfern erkannt worden als er
in deutschland lebte heißt dass ob so
jemand zur verantwortung gezogen wird
das hängt immer noch vom zufall ab
ja also voraussetzung für ein solches
strafverfahren wegen völkerrechts
verbrechen ist eben dass die person in
deutschland anwesend ist und das war in
diesem fall der fall zugleich waren die
entsprechenden beweismittel hier in
deutschland verfügbar und wenn sie
wollen ist das ein stück weit eben auch
zufall gewesen dass diese person gerade
zu diesem zeitpunkt in deutschland
ergriffen worden ist jetzt ist
strafrecht ja immer
einzelfallprüfung was kann uns dieser
prozess trotzdem bringen für weitere
verfahren
also von koblenz geht ein ganz starkes
signal aus die botschaft lautet
diejenigen die für völkerrechts
verbrechen in staatlichen funktionen
verantwortlich sind für schwerste
menschenrechtsverbrechen in der welt die
finden in deutschland keinen sicheren
hafen die können sich nicht sicher sein
dass sie vor strafrechtlicher
verantwortlich verantwortung sicher sind
und dafür steht dieser prozess der im
übrigen auch deswegen eine premiere ist
weil weltweit erstmals ein gericht
festgestellt hat dass auch diejenigen
die in staatlichen funktionen in syrien
am volk folter apparat beteiligt sind
verantwortlich sind ist das jetzt quasi
so ein neuer weg vorbei am
internationalen strafgerichtshof den es
ja auch noch gibt er aber einigermaßen
lahm gelegt scheint hin zu normalen
gerichten sage ich jetzt mal
was ist eigentlich schon seit langer
zeit so dass dieses system
internationaler strafrechtspflege was
eben genau sicherstellen soll dass
solche verbrechen nicht straflos bleiben
aus verschiedenen bausteinen besteht
daher gibt es internationale
strafgerichte insbesondere den
internationalen strafgerichtshof da gibt
es aber auch staatliche strafgerichte
wie die deutschen etwa die eine wichtige
rolle dabei spielen solche verbrecher
abzuurteilen und sie tun das auf
grundlage eines prinzips des
weltrechtsprinzip was es eben erhöht
nicht dass auch staaten in denen die tat
nicht unmittelbar begangen worden sind
tätig werden das gericht heute in
koblenz geht über diesen einzelfall in
bemerkenswerter weise auch noch hin aus
und sagt der fall sei teil der
systematischen folterpraxis des assad
regimes in syrien und zwar über
jahrzehnte hinweg
können diktatoren mit dem heutigen tag
schlechter schlafen als vorher
ja also sicherlich geht von dieser
entscheidung eine wichtige botschaft aus
wie gesagt man muss sie allerdings sehen
in einem größeren zusammenhang nämlich
von vielen verfahren die in deutschland
stattgefunden haben und noch stattfinden
die in anderen europäischen staaten
stattfinden und die eben vor
internationalen strafgerichten
stattfinden und die alle die botschaft
vermitteln staatliche folter staatliche
menschenrechtsverletzungen bleiben nicht
straflos sondern es gibt institutionen
die die strafverfolgung sicher stellen
also das ist ein symbol das ist ein
signal dass da heute ausgeht jetzt hat
sich das gericht an syrien abgearbeitet
aktuell aber was ist zum beispiel mit
der folter in ägypten die
menschenrechtler ja auch immer
anprangern da hört man ja nichts kann
man sagen aus deutschland sucht sich die
justiz da die für sie passenden länder
raus
ja es ist ganz wichtig dass viele blinde
flecken bleiben dabei wenn man über die
durchsetzung dieser rechtsprinzipien
spricht und es geht jetzt darum diese
blinden flecken weiter zu schließen ein
besonderer aspekt dieses verfahrens in
koblenz war etwa dass dort nicht nur
eine erfahrene strafverfolgungsbehörde
der generalbundesanwalt mitgewirkt hat
sondern auch zivilgesellschaftliche
kräfte einen beitrag geleistet haben und
insbesondere auch die syrische
gemeinschaft in deutschland die alle
zusammen ist möglich gemacht haben dass
diese strafverfahren
erfolgreich jedenfalls mit einer
verurteilung abgeschlossen werden konnte
und was sagen sie den kritikern die
sagen und die bemängeln da urteilen
jetzt richter eines anderen landes eines
anderen politischen systems sehr weit
weg über zustände in an fremden staat
ja die erfahrung lehrt dass immer dann
wenn solche schwersten verbrechen mit
staatlicher beteiligung begangen werden
dass immer dann oder oft dann diese
verbrechen straflos bleiben und genau
das ist der grund weswegen die
internationale ordnung das
internationale recht in einem engen
bereich schwerster verbrechen
kriegsverbrechen menschlichkeit
verbrechen völkermord es eben allen
staaten der welt erlaubt durch ihre
gerichte einen beitrag dazu zu leisten
dass diese straflosigkeit beendet wird
und genau das ist hier der fall und der
fall zeigt vielleicht auch dass es
vielleicht nicht ideal ist das
strafverfahren hier weit entfernt vom
tatort zu führen dass es aber möglich
ist und eben oft auch nötig ist sagt
professor florian jesberger von der
berliner humboldt uni herzlichen dank
für das gespräch ich danke ihnen
bis heute sind mehr als 100.000 menschen
in syrischen foltergefängnissen
verschwunden von vielen fehlt immer noch
jede spur ein menschenrechtler der in
syrien selbst gefoltert wurde sagt heute
das urteil wird die opfer nicht zu ihren
familien zurück bringen aber es gibt uns
die hoffnung dass die regie mehr fallen
und wir frei sein werden
so hanna hat jetzt weitere wichtige
nachrichten hier im überblick
bei einem treffen der eu außen und
verteidigungsminister im französischen
brest ging es auch um das verhältnis zu
russland bundes aussenministerin wer
bock plädierte für ein geschlossenes und
starkes auftreten der eu und will weiter
auf dialog setzen
wie heute bekannt wurde trifft berbalk
am dienstag ihren russischen
amtskollegen lawrow in moskau der kreml
zog derweil eine negative bilanz der
gespräche mit den usa und der nato in
dieser woche vize aussenminister riad
koch zeigte sich in einem
fernsehinterview enttäuscht er sehe in
naher zukunft keinen anlass für eine
fortsetzung der gespräche über den
ukraine konflikt
die ständige impfkommission empfiehlt
nun auch für alle 12 bis 17 jährigen
eine booster impfung mit dem aktien von
biotech kaiser und das frühestens drei
monate nach der zweiten impfung
als grund wird unter anderem die
ausbreitung der omicron variante genannt
und die dadurch befürchtete belastungen
des gesundheitssystems
auch heute wurde wieder ein neuer
höchststand bei den neuinfektionen
binnen eines tages registriert dieser
liegt bei 81 1417 das sind 17 1077 mehr
als vor einer woche
316 menschen starben die 77 tages
incidents ist auf 427 sieben gestiegen
wegen der stark steigenden
infektionszahlen hat
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
eindringlich dazu aufgerufen sich impfen
zu lassen
in der bundestagsdebatte zur
gesundheitspolitik sprach sich
lauterbach erneut für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht aus und nannte sie den
sichersten und schnellsten weg aus der
krise die union forderte den
gesundheitsminister dazu auf einen
eigenen gesetzentwurf dazu vorzulegen
wegen falscher impf bescheinigungen hat
die polizei in mehreren bundesländern
wohnungen durchsucht bei mehr als 100
personen stellte sie impfausweise und
smartphones sicher außerdem wurde bei
verdächtigen blut abgenommen um deren
impfstatus zu klären hintergrund ist der
fall eines hausarztes aus bayern dieser
soll impfungen vorgetäuscht und falsche
bescheinigungen ausgestellt haben
verzweifelte eltern verwirrte kinder
verärgerte lehrer corona und die schulen
das ist ein ganz eigenes thema und zwar
seit beginn dieser pandemie und zwar
nicht nur bei uns frankreich erlebt
heute einen der größten schule proteste
der letzten jahre und frankreich hat
schon viele schul proteste erlebt die
schulen sollen offen bleiben das ist
erklärtes ziel der französischen
regierung ein wütender vater ergänzte
heute aber niemand hat gesagt ob auch
lehrer und schüler drin sein soll die
strategie die eben auch in der pandemie
das aufrechterhalten will was schule
bieten sollte kommt mit omikron an ihre
grenzen sie hat risiken und
nebenwirkungen wie thomas walter zeigt
keine schule das hieß heute morgen in
einem vorort von paris das immanuel
nicola seine kinder madeline und marta
selbst betreuen und dafür von zu hause
arbeiten musste trotzdem unterstützt
nicola den schulstreik
die schutzmaßnahmen in der schule machen
keinen sinn sie werden nicht verstanden
von den lehrern nicht vom personal und
nicht von den kindern es ist ein
ständiges hin und her
streiks von lehrern gab es in frankreich
öfter einen streik den eltern
organisationen unterstützen nicht so oft
heute gingen sie gemeinsam in vielen
städten des landes auf die straße
sie fordern mehr schutz vor dem virus
und eine klare linie der regierung
wir streiken weil wir das
krisenmanagement im nationalen
schulwesen kritisieren er es geht um die
art die sehr autoritär ist neue regeln
werden zunächst in der presse
angekündigt und gelten ab sofort
wir haben keine ausstattung keine masken
für die kinder oder lehrer wir haben
keine vertretungen und müssen uns
durchschlagen
wir sind zu wenige lehrer pro klasse wir
müssen mehr einstellen
lehrer und eltern ärger dass die
regierung die schutzregeln lockert
bisher wurden kinder in apotheken
getestet wegen der steigenden zahlen gab
es lange schlangen darum sollen künftig
selbst es reichen wenn es in einer
klasse co virtuelle gibt nur positiv
getestete kinder müssen dann nach hause
der schulbetrieb soll unbedingt
weitergehen
das schließen der schulen würde kinder
aus der bahn werfen ihren lernerfolg
gefährden und ihre kontakte mit anderen
kindern das wäre zutiefst ungerecht
schulen zu schließen dieses profil oder
vermieter die regierung will aus der
ersten corona welle lernen damals hatte
frankreich seine schulen geschlossen vor
allem in sozialen brennpunkten mit
gravierenden folgen viele kinder hatten
keinen zugang zu digitalem lernen und
die vielen der schulspeisung spürten sie
besonders doch die aktuelle strategie
der regierung stößt an grenzen
es ist sehr sehr sehr schwierig weil wir
eine starke zunahme an cupid fällen
haben diese geschwindigkeit
wir so nicht
so hängt omikron über allem die zahl der
infektionen macht es schwerer den
einzelnen zu schützen und kritische
infrastruktur aufrecht zu halten das
lernt frankreich nicht nur für die
schule sondern für das leben
nervös gucken die lehrerinnen und lehrer
eltern und deren kinder auch bei uns auf
die entwicklung und nicht nur die torge
bode nimmt uns jetzt mit ins uniklinikum
bochum wo die einen nicht weiter können
und die anderen gerade erst anfangen
frühschicht für rico back höfer für sie
ist es tag eins auf der intensivstation
der katholischen uni klinik bochum im
rahmen eines praktikums denn die
25-jährige ist noch in der ausbildung
berufswunsch intensiv krankenpflegerin
und das in zeiten von corona
aber
wie dringend rica berghöfer gebraucht
wird sieht man auf der nächsten station
denn in fast jeder schicht fehlt hier
mindestens eine pflegekraft
[Applaus]
in der 8 liegt ein komapatient im
kritischen zustand im laufe der pandemie
musste intensiv krankenpflegerin anna
michalski viele menschen sterben sehen
und das obwohl sie doch alle hier jeden
tag ihr bestes gegeben haben und noch
immer geben das frustriert und belastet
die seele
man geht nicht um einen guten gefühl
nach hause man möchte halt seine arbeit
nach seinem nach seinen westen standards
erfüllen und wenn das nicht gegeben ist
die situation auch was das personal
angeht wechsel viele leute halt den
beruf sowie luisa haas vier jahre dienst
auf der intensivstation die pandemie hat
sie hautnah in einer großen klinik im
ruhrgebiet erlebt irgendwann ging es der
25 jährigen zu
wenn jemand stirbt das ist niemals schön
so
aber wenn das halt so geballt kommt wird
es halt schwierig wenn man sich da
zwischen nicht davon erholen kann
das nicht verarbeiten kann weil es
einfach so viele patienten waren
professor felix weiter beobachtet seit
jahren die situation der pflegekräfte
auf den intensivstationen
deutschlandweit dass immer mehr
pflegerinnen und pfleger kündigen lege
auch an der mangelnden unterstützung bei
psychischen belastungen so der
intensivmediziner
wir wissen von der bundeswehr dass
menschen mit potenziell schwerwiegenden
ereignissen erheblich besser umgehen
wenn sie eine psychosoziale
unterstützung bekommen aber das hat ist
in deutschland in krankenhäusern
mitnichten in irgendeiner form sinnvoll
implementiert war luisa haas keine zeit
zum durchatmen hatte keine zeit für sich
das erlebte zu verarbeiten hat sie jetzt
ihren job gekündigt eine rückkehr in die
pflege kommt für sie unter den
derzeitigen bedingungen nicht in frage
damit ist sie nicht allein
ganz konkret geht mit mir gemeinsam eine
dezember eine andere kollegin noch und
ende januar noch zwei weitere von denen
ich weiß und ich glaube es sind nicht
die letzten die gehen rica berghöfer
dagegen freut sich auf ihren neuen job
als intensiv krankenpflegerin sie brennt
darauf neue erfahrungen zu sammeln im
märz will sie das examen machen die
politik muss jetzt dafür sorgen dass ihr
feuereifer nicht schnell wieder erlischt
wir gucken jetzt mit hanna auf die
wirtschaft und dort auf sorgen an der
küste ganz genau
1.900 mitarbeiter der mv werften in
mecklenburg vorpommern bangen aktuell um
ihren arbeitsplatz das war auch thema im
schweriner landtag heute und es gab
zumindest eine kleine positive meldung
für die mitarbeiter konkret man an der
frankfurter börse welche genau und wie
steht es ansonsten um die rettung der
standorte
naja immerhin wurde der belegschaft
heute mitgeteilt dass die ausstehenden
löhne spätestens am montag gezahlt
werden und dass das geld bis
einschließlich februar gesichert sein
darüber hinaus aber müssen sich alle
werftarbeiter sowohl in rostock als auch
in wismar und stralsund auf eine
zitterpartie einstellen alles hängt
davon ab ob das fast fertige kreuzfahrer
schiff global one imbiss mara doch zu
ende gebaut und verkauft werden kann
ursprünglichen auftrag gegeben vom
eigner der mv werften vom asiatischen
konzern genthin wir brauchen einen
abnehmer für das schiff der abnehmer
agentin ist selbst so wie man es aus der
presse jedenfalls lesen kann selbst auch
angeschlagen aufgrund der kona pandemie
und das ist für mich jedenfalls noch
nicht klar ob
lenting als abnehmer zur verfügung steht
das fertige kreuzfahrtschiff gilt mit
platz für knapp 10.000 passagiere als
eines der größten der welt und soll rund
1,5 milliarden euro wert sein denn ding
aber steckt in schwierigkeiten nach der
insolvenz der mv werften ist die aktie
des asiatischen mutterkonzerns heute um
über 50 prozent eingebrochen scheitert
der verkauf könnte es eng werden
ministerpräsidentin schwesig sicherte
heute jedenfalls schon mal zu sie werde
sich für hilfen von land und bund
einsetzen
vielen dank nach frankfurt
genau zehn jahre nach dem unglück der
costa concordia wurde heute auf der
italienischen insel guilio der opfer
gedacht den ganzen tag erinnerten
hinterbliebene und anwohner an die
verstorbenen und legten kränze nieder
costa concordia hatte am 13 januar 2012
bei einem riskanten manöver einen felsen
gerammt 32 menschen starben darunter 12
deutsche der kapitän des
kreuzfahrtschiffes wurde zu einer
haftstrafe von 16 jahren verurteilt
der schriftsteller filmemacher und maler
herbert achternbusch ist tot der
künstler starb im alter von 83 jahren in
seiner heimatstadt münchen achternbusch
provozierte mit skurrilen film wie bier
kampf oder das gespenst und legte sich
mit der katholischen kirche an sein
lebenswerk umfasst neben zahlreichen
filmen mehr als 20 theaterstücke 40
bücher und hunderte gemälde
zum sport beim biathlon weltcup in
ruhpolding hat benedikt doll den zweiten
platz im sprint belegt sein bisher
bestes ergebnis in diesem olympia winter
nach fehlerfreiem schießen war der
sprint weltmeister von 2017
7,2 sekunden langsamer als der
gesamtweltcupführende phion ag aus
frankreich ihre gläser wurde sechster
die norwegischen top athleten waren
nicht am start
er ist nach allem was man weiß ihr
lieblingssohn oder er war es vielleicht
ein grund warum die queen sehr lange
gewartet hat bis zum heutigen abend an
dem sie andrew duke of york endgültig
fallen lässt sie hat ihm alle
militärischen dienst gerade entzogen und
alle royalen schirmherrschaften andrew
muss sich als privater bürger
verteidigen wenden dann der prozess in
den usa beginnt in dem ihm eine klägerin
vorwirft sie als minderjährige mehrfach
missbraucht zu haben die nachricht heute
abend hat großbritannien aufgewühlt wie
diana zimmermann berichtet
als königliche hoheit come and throw
heute nach winzer als ein königssohn der
seinen titel nicht mehr nutzen wird
verließ er das schloss seiner mutter mit
genehmigungen und zustimmungen der queen
so wörtlich gab deren zweitältester sohn
heute auch seine militärischen ehren
zurück sie werden nun an andere
mitglieder der königlichen familie
verteilt sehr viel dunkler hätte das
jahr in dem queen elizabeth ihr 70
thronjubiläum feiern will für sie nicht
beginnen können
es ist grauenvoll für die queen ganz
eindeutig musste sie druck auf ihren
lieblingssohn ausüben damit er seine
titel und schirmherrschaften aufgibt und
ein privatmensch wird
das königshaus reagiert vermutlich vor
allem auf druck der garde grenadiere die
ihren langsam unerträglichen ehrenoberst
loswerden wollten gestern hatte ein
richter in new york einen antrag endlos
abgelehnt der die klage von wird sehen
ja zu früh gegen ihn aus formalen
gründen stoppen sollte die 38 jährige
wirft dem königssohn vor er habe sie vor
20 jahren missbraucht andrew weiss das
konsequent zurück doch der richter in
new york erwartet von andrew rede und
antwort im für den herbst geplanten
verfahren so solle etwa beweisen dass er
wirklich nicht schwitzen kann eine
störung die enduro auf seinen einsatz im
falklandkrieg zurückführt und mit der
jeffries behauptung er habe bei ihren
insgesamt drei zusammenkünften sehr
stark geschwitzt entkräften wollte schon
lange als einziger halbwegs ehrenhafte
lösung gefordert könnte andrew nach new
york reisen und sich dem prozess einfach
stellen
er möchte das ganz sicher vermeiden denn
wenn er dort aus sagt entsteht das
risiko dass er als straftäter
festgenommen werden könnte
roßleben daran der schmerzensgeldprozess
aber ein zivilverfahren ist droht andrew
keine auslieferung
kann ihnen nicht in die vereinigten
staaten zwingen sie kann nicht mal zur
aussage zwingen das problem ist aber
dass für zivilprozesse gilt wenn man
sich nicht verteidigt gewinnt die
anklage träumen williams die einzige
möglichkeit den prozess abzuwenden wäre
eine außergerichtliche einigung
inzwischen aber streute fries anwalt
zweifel ob seine mandantin dazu
überhaupt bereit wäre zu früh an opfer
von andrews freundin jeffrey epstein und
gelang max will die beide für schuldig
befunden wurden mit minderjährigen sex
handel betrieben zu haben verlangen
gerechtigkeit er weiß genau was er getan
hat
andrew beharrt auf seiner unschuld und
will sich weiter verteidigen the fray
will eine entschuldigung und vermutlich
viel geld das wohl die queen zahlen
müsste auch wenn ihr gefallen der sohn
nur noch ein privatmensch ist
in der prozess beginnt stünde dann vor
gericht also der privatmann andrew
albert christian adword
mountbatten-windsor
unkomplizierter und für das königshaus
potenziell weniger verheerend wird es
deshalb nicht
ein thema das alle umtreibt gleich bei
maybrit illner welle oder wände ändert
omikron die korona politik gleich nach
und gegen 0.30 spricht da sein sagt er
mir im heute-journal update mit dem
virologen ulf dittmer von der uniklinik
essen unter anderem zur lage auf den
intensivstationen von uns allen hier im
heute schon mal thiemann sie einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend hoch carlos hält ja schon
ziemlich lange durch morgen bekommt es
unterstützung durch das tiefbauamt
das bringt mich ein paar dichtere wolken
die zumindest mal über den osten
deutschlands ziehen und auch ein kleines
bisschen nieselregen dabei haben die
dichteren wolken merken wir jetzt schon
in der nach dem süden ist es zum teil
wieder klar und es bildet sich nebel es
wird wieder sehr kalt am alpenrand
sinken die temperaturen bis minus zehn
grad auch sonst sollten sie sich auf
blätter einstellen wenn es irgendwo
feucht glitzert nur hier im äußersten
norden unter den dichteren wolken ist es
bei 6 bis 4 grad zu mild für glätte und
morgen liegen die temperaturen dann
zwischen 6 und 9 grad und nur wenn sich
der nebel c hält dann bleibt es bei
werten kaum über dem gefrierpunkt und
auch morgen wird es wieder trüb bleiben
hier in süddeutschland zum teil dabei
scheint die sonne auch strahlend am
alpenrand zum beispiel da wird es dann
auch sehr wild und auch auf den
berggipfel in norddeutschland sind die
wolken dichter und bringe ein bisschen
nieselregen mit spätestens am nachmittag
lockern die wolken dann aber bei einem
starken zum bei stürmischem nordwestwind
an der küste auch wieder auf und jetzt
schauen wir uns den sonntag an denn der
sieht eigentlich ganz ähnlich aus wie
der freitagmorgen da kommt wieder ein
tief heran das sieht so aus als würde es
schnee bringen den bringt es aber nur
osteuropa und streift uns wirklich nur
im äußersten osten am samstag wird sich
noch nichts ändern am sonntag kommt von
norden etwas regen heran und am montag
könnte es dann für ein paar
schneeflocken in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen reichen und fiel
insgesamt